hello everyone I hope you're all having
a great Sunday there's this new thing on
YouTube called community posts so far
you could only post videos on YouTube
but now you can write some sentences to
your subscribers you can maybe upload
some images do some announcements but
most importantly you can do a polls so I
decided to do a poll this morning and
asked you guys what video length do you
prefer and it seems that most of you
don't mind longer videos as long as the
content content is interesting so as
it's Sunday I decided to do a video
about the endgame while we're waiting
for the London chess classic round two
now for this video I chose a game
between Bobby Fischer and mark time and
from there were two final candidates
match in 1971 I already did the game
Game three of this match this is Game
four I will put a link in the
description below
in that video I said something more
about Mark Damon off and the history of
this match if you are interested but for
this game I will mostly be focusing on
the endgame because I remember when I
started studying chess some more than 10
years ago I know I studied some tile
games I studied some 11 games I was
mostly interested in the middle game and
in attacking and this this was sometimes
useful but whenever I faced a stronger
opponent you know a stronger the phone
opponent will find great defensive
resources and will be able to transfer
the game into the endgame and if you're
not a good end game player you're gonna
lose the game and you're gonna lose most
of the games like that especially
especially in situations when you don't
know whether to enter the endgame or not
for example I lost so many games because
I've avoided a queen trade just just for
the sole purpose of avoiding the Queen
trade I wanted the Queen's to stay on
the board although the endgame was
favorable to me so that's why it's
extremely important to study the endgame
I think Botvinnik once said that no one
becomes a world champion if they don't
master the endgame and I also enjoy
something a grandmaster igor smirnov
said he said
openings are for players of 2400 and
above and I definitely agree with this
there is nothing worse I think then when
someone starts learning chess and he
starts studying the openings this is
something also Josh Waitzkin always
talked about he said that he always so
lost in the opening but then because he
studied the end game so much he almost
always out plays his opponent in the end
game so that being said let's see this
game the famous 1970 watch work 1971
quarter final candidates match against
Bobby Fischer and mark time of Bobby has
the white pieces and like I said I will
mostly be focusing on the endgame efore
c5 the Sicilian defense Knight to f3
knight c6 d4c capture son before ninth
chapter 74 and Queen to c7 the floor
variation a Knight to c3 e six now this
is called the time and of variation g3
and a6 now Bishop to g2 nice to have six
Fischer castles nice character Sundy for
Queen captures on d4 and Bishop to c5
here Fischer plays a bishop to F for now
attacking at the time when I was Queen
d6 this is definitely the best move
Queen d2 and now h6 rook a to d 1e five
Bishop to e3 and Bishop to g4 and here
Fischer already plays an interesting
move but definitely the best move he
plays Bishop captures and c5 seemingly
seemingly allowing time enough to
capture the rook on d1 but this doesn't
work if Bishop captures on d1 then Queen
Bishop captures on d6 now what a tempo
on the Queen and after something like
rook to d8 simply rook captures and e1
and you have two pieces for the rook
this is completely winning for white
after something like Queen c6 Bishop to
h3 you're completely controlling the
game
knife characters e4 simply doesn't work
after Knight capture screen captures and
the Queen c3
there is really nothing you can do rook
to e1 is coming threatening the five
pawn if you play something like f6 Queen
b3 and there is no defense against Queen
three six so this would fall apart for
black pretty quickly so dr. Bishop to c5
time it doesn't capture the rook we have
D captures and c5 and now f3 improving
this central structure and forcing the
spawn kicking the bishop away Bishop to
e6 and now f4 rook to d8 was played
Bishop to g4 again doesn't really
achieve anything for black because of
Queen to d6 now you either have to
exchange Queens either way this bishops
attack on the rook isn't really
accomplishing anything so after a four
route to d8 now Knight to d5 Bishop
captures he captures and now e for rook
F to e one you can't capture the pawn
with some rookie want ideas because f5
simply covers everything for black so
after a four rook F t1 was played and
now rook captures on d5 attacking
Fischer's queen and grabbing the pawn
but Fischer has an answer to this he
plays rook captures on e4
now if you capture the rook Fischer
captures rook can be 5 so King to d8 now
still the queen is attacked and Fisher's
rook is attacked but Queen to e2 now if
you capture the rook with the night for
example Knight captures on e4 rook
captures and after something like Knight
to d6 Queen to e5 and there is no
defense
you can't save this night King d7 to h3
check and now after King ba you're
simply getting checkmated
so after Queen e2 time of capture rook
capture Sun be one Queen captures on d1
and here we have Queen to d7 and this is
a what I enjoy about this game this is a
very important decision Fischer has to
make what does he trade Queen's or
doesn't he trait Queens
you have to realize a couple of things
if you were if you will be able to
decide this
Fischer traded Queens Queen captures and
naga king captures and how do you
evaluate this position this endgame well
let's see both players have three points
on the King side and both players have a
three sorry on the Queen side and both
players have three points on the King
side Fischer has a bishop against a
knight this is always slightly better
especially if there are pawns on both
sides of the board this Bishop can you
know shift sides I'm much faster than
tonight Fischer's rook is a bit more
active but time I was rook can easily
enter the game with rook to the 8th and
the time enough has a slightly more
active King so why did Fischer enter the
endgame why did Fischer evaluate that
this was better for him well you'll see
rook the e5 and one other thing Fischer
always had a like extremely big
confidence in his endgame skills rock to
e5 and here already we have the critical
moment in the endgame here time enough
has a choice when Fischer played rook to
e5 he's now attacking the c5 pawn and
the bishop is attacking the b7 pawn so
there's a those are two threats diamond
has to deal with
and unfortunately for time enough time
enough played b6 now which seems like
the right decision you know you you lock
your pawns and dark squares you know
they're not gonna be easy targets for
Fischer's Bishop also to b6 bone now
defends the c5 pawn so it seems all as
well next time I know explaining rook to
d8 King to d6 and he he considers this
to be a good position but as you'll see
this this will not be the case a better
move after up to e5 was actually King to
d6 defending the pawn with the Queen the
King and now Bishop captures an b7
simply doesn't work
I mean after Bishop captures rook to b8
Bishop captures a six now raakhi after
some b2 and after something like rook to
e2 defending row captures Bishop to c4
attacking the rook and the f7 pawn but
simply rook to a7
and if diamond went for this there's
still equal material
but now there is only one point on each
side on the Queen side and now the
bishops the bishops advantage over a
knight isn't so great because there are
far less targets for the bishop to hone
on and the timing of skiing is still now
a lot more active than Fisher skiing his
rook is active on a seven this would
have been perfectly fine and probably
easily easily drawn I don't think I mean
who knows you know me
maybe Fisher would win this but it's a
lot better than what time I went for
after up to e5 he played b6 thinking
that this was all fine but this actually
creates a big problem for time on earth
and this is why Fischer excelled in end
games when time enough pushed b6 he now
has a week a six pawn and the week f7
pawn both both on light squares and
Fischer immediately takes advantage of
this he plays Bishop to f1 with a temple
on the a6 born we had a five and now
Bishop to c4 so Fisher improves the
position of his Bishop honing on the two
two weak weak bones and the white
squares the a6 pawn and now on the f7
pawn only way you can defend the f7
point is by playing rook to f8 so this
is what's the amount of plays and now as
you can see Fischer prevented time on of
at least four two moves for now for
improving his King for example with King
to d6 and he's also not allowing the
rook to enter the game with rook to e8
and maybe allow an exchange of rooks
came to g2 now Fischer starts improving
the position of his own King King d6 and
now King to f3 and already you can see
that time I've had a much more active
King already now Fischer's King is also
active and this rook still can't enter
the game we have Knight to d7 with a
temple on the rook rook to e3 and now
Knight the b8 now time at all wants to
activate his knight which moves like
Knight to c6 and then perhaps entering
to be 4 or d4 so Fisher plays rook to d3
with check first King to c7 and now
three a time out of place Knight to c6
but now this pawn and c3 Fischer plate
is controlling b4 is controlling d4 the
pawn on f5 is controlling easy five so
the knight can't enter the game room to
e3 and now taking away one more square
for from the knight now the knight can't
really go anywhere on only backwards
King to d6 and the now a4 and with this
a for move official walks down this
opponent b6 it can never be pushed to b5
and also Fischer is creating a plan he's
creating a plan for his King to enter
the Queen side we had the light squares
with king he to king d3 king c4 king b5
and king to a6 so Knight to e7
we have h3 and Knight to c6 now Knight
to d5 of course doesn't work rook to d3
pins it you lose the piece and for
example Knight to f5 simply rook to e2
and the night still doesn't really have
any any future
you still can't develop the rook the f7
point is hanging g4 is a possibility any
time so after h3 time enough plays
Knight to c6 back and now h4 we have h5
not allowing Fischer to expand with the
g4 rope to d3 check first King c7 and
out rook to d5 improving the position of
the rook again would a temple on the h5
pawn and here time on of can play g6 or
f5 he decided to go for f5 and both
moves are of equal quality he probably
played f5 so this f7 pawn won't stay at
target anymore but now rook to d2 now
Fischer is ready to bring the room back
to the e-file rook f6 and rook to e2 now
King d7 rook to e3
we have g6 and Bishop to b5 pinning the
night rook to d6 now King to e2 came to
d8 and now rook to d3 and now Fischer
created everything he wanted to do he
locked down the
on the kingside on the light squares so
there will be an easy target for his
bishop and he locked the kingside bones
on the dark squares so the King can
enter the position on the Queen side so
king c7 and now Fisher knows that this
is better for him and he exchanges rooks
rogue capture screen captures and King
to d3 and it's it's a very hard endgame
for black you can play something like
King to d5 to improve the position of
your own King because Bishop captures
and c6 wins the game immediately King
captures and after King to c4 you can
stop the white team from entering the
position King D 6 King bee 5 King c7 now
King a 6
now if you push c4 then King bee five
wins that pawn if you continue with
something like king c6 you get c4 king
c7 king a7 and after King to c6 and king
b8 you have to move and now the King
comes to be 7 and this gobbling up all
these pawns
so after king d3 you can't play King to
d5 Knight to e7 now Fischer plays Bishop
to be 8 attacking the g6 pawn now this
Knight is stuck there defending it came
to d5 but now Bishop to f7 forcing the
King bat while still threatening to
capture the g6 pawn king 36 and alkene
to c4 and Fischer is slowly but surely
making way with his King all the way to
the Queen side now King to c6 now but we
ate check king came to b7 and our King
to b5 Knight to c8 and this is a this is
a great moment in the game tamaño offers
Fischer the g6 bond and this would have
been a historic moment if Fischer
actually captured it because Knight to
d6 is checkmate
so of course Fischer doesn't fall for
this after Knight to c8 Bishop to c6
check King to see King to c7 and now
Bishop to d5 and now Knight coming to d6
we'll check isn't really doing anything
since the king can come to a 6 which
Fisher's plan all along Knight to e7 now
attacking the bishop bishop to f7 again
forcing the knight to defend the g6 pawn
king the b7 and now we have Bishop to b3
King to a7 and Bishop to d1 and this is
a Fisher's idea he now wants to transfer
the bishop all the way to f3 to prevent
the King from being able to to go either
to a7 or b7 King Tubby 7 was played and
this was one moment in the position
where time enough could have activated
the night with a more like Knight to d5
but after King to c6 now Fischer has a
Fisher's active King is too powerful and
this Bishop is coming to b3 g 6 f7 and
will gobble up all of these points this
is winning for white if you if you want
you can you know fool around with this
position for a bit it's a it's a winning
for white so after Bishop to d1 we have
King backed it would be 7 and the bishop
to f3 with check forcing the King to c7
and now King to a6 and Fischer
accomplished what he had planned way
before he ever decided to trade that
rook this was his plan would move a four
locking down the pawn and everything is
going his way
Knight the g8 now we have Bishop to d5
attacking the knight Knight to e7 and
here
Bishop to f7 is a good move but it's not
the best move after something like King
to c6 Bishop to a check and king to c7
now it's Fisher's move but Fischer wants
this exact position but he wants it to
be time when I was move so after Knight
to e7 Fischer first place Bishop c4 now
we have Knight to c6 and now Bishop 12 7
which tempo
Knight to e7 and now Bishop to eh and
now it's that exact same position only
now it's time a nice move and what do
you play here the knight can't move it
has to protect the g6 pawn the King
can't move it has to protect the B
six pawn so only move terminal really
has is came to d8 now the king isn't
defending the bb6 born but also Fisher's
Bishop is attacked but this was Fisher's
plan all along now official plays Bishop
captures on g6 Knight captures on g6 and
King captures and b6 and often in n
games where you have pawns on both sides
of the board this is why Bishop is much
better than a knight
because he can create threats on both
sides of the board and here it's pretty
obvious that Fischer has quite enough
compensation for the piece King D 7 now
King captures and c5 97 and I'll be four
immediately creating a passed pawn a
capture some before C capture some
before Knight to c8 a5 the past pawns
are coming up the board 96 b5 now 94
check now King to b6 King c8 and kink
the c6 not long anymore checks from the
night as you know when the when the King
and the night are in this exact
formation there is a one diagonal square
in between them it takes the night for
most checked to check the King so this
is a useful information for when you
play like blitz and bullet games you
know if you want to put your king
somewhere where the knight can't check
it and then just use this opposition
King the b8 was played and now b6 and in
this position marked Imanol resigned the
game and Fischer is leading in the match
for 2-0 but like I said I will put a
link in the description below from round
3 of this match where you can learn
something more about mark time and off
and this match itself so yeah that's the
game I hope you enjoyed it it's a bit
different than some of the other videos
as this is mostly mostly about the
endgame I am a big fan of attacking
chess and games of Michael Tao and such
players but I also enjoyed the endgame I
also enjoyed positional chests I just
suck at it but I I do enjoy playing the
endgame Center I consider myself pretty
good at end games so yeah you might
wonder why I chose a game by Bobby
Fischer
you how to play the endgame I could have
shown your game by me by Mikhail
Botvinnik or for example Capablanca or
emmanuel ask her those were all amazing
and game players but the fact of the
matter is that you know Fischer was
promoting chess more than anyone in the
world during his lifetime and he is
still promoting chess even now that he's
dead because people are simply more
interested in seeing a game played by
Bobby Fischer so I know that by telling
you to study the end game because
Fischer played the endgame well more of
you will maybe maybe get the urge to
start studying the endgame so that's why
I chose a Fischer game so yeah like I
said I hope I hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Sam wheeler and
against us bossy for a contribution to
my channel thank a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here I will make
the upper video game three from this
match thank y'all for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with a nice
game from the one and chest classic
round two